what up guys welcome to the just pearly
things youtube channel today we're doing
another car
chat um and i've brought on my cousin
maddie
we're gonna ask her some questions today
on the channel
um just about stuff i've learned in the
manosphere she isn't really
familiar with manosphere content are you
nervous a little bit
yeah so tell them a little bit about
your dating history
ooh so how many boyfriends have you had
probably like about five like casually
dating and then i have my boyfriend now
for two years
so tell me you i actually talk a lot
about on the channel
how i actually think it's really harmful
to say things like men are trash
i think men are trash though not all of
them i mean people are trash
right like i don't want to just single
out men men affect
me the most in the trashy way men cause
me important problems women
in my daily life how how so
i don't just like their existence
sometimes just like angers me
or they'll just like say [ __ ] like i
work at a daycare
and like the dads will come in and be
like well i didn't know it was
like this day or something i'll be like
so now i'm going to spend 10 minutes
arguing with your child to put there's
something on because you didn't want to
read a note
like that's just a man thing the mom
would have said snacks
i think women it's like equal with like
the trashy things that women do yeah but
like
women you also expect it every time like
if i know a woman like is hitting on my
boyfriend
i already know what she's doing it's
annoying it's [ __ ] i'll put her in
her place like
in a situation but like a man like
they'll be like oh
like they just don't get it they think
that's without happening or they i don't
know they don't get one
they like they don't get when people are
either hitting on them or like when
other dudes didn't know their woman like
it's not
the same they'll be like no like you're
not like no one's sitting on you like
that's not what's happening they're just
your friend
oh so you think like men are oblivious
to me yeah or like just
like in general like they're oblivious
and so like all their actions
affect other people and that's what's
attractive i'm just confused do you
think women
are like dumber or dumber than that oh i
don't i mean not necessarily like an
education wise but like socially wise
like small little things like
emotionally wise i would say a lot of
the time they are
at least my man but like like you know
how a woman a girl wants flowers right
but i don't want to have to tell you
that i want flowers the guys will be
like well if you don't tell me then how
am i gonna
because you know like you know this but
you're choosing to not think about it
and you want me to tell you exactly
exactly step by step so you're not
stupid you're just choosing
to be ignorant well do you think it's
just like the men you choose to date
because no but it's not just men i did
it like it says dad's the daycare
it's it's dudes cutting you off in
[ __ ] parking lots be like i didn't
see you
i drive a nest i drive a [ __ ] big ass
accurate you did see me
right i don't know i've just seen women
like do equally trashy things maybe
you're around trash you're on it i don't
also
you don't even like i know women like i
mean women can be really trashy i
i think again like i said people are
trapped it's irresponsible to have like
say three kids with three different dads
no that's very good yeah i'm not trying
to climb the mom's the daycare but
yes you know what i'm saying so like to
me
that's actually like a lot of times if
you have kids with the wrong person
that's something but that means that dad
probably has multiple kids too
no absolutely so like i think people are
trash but i think
arguably like i said in my life men are
trashy to me
and they affect me more well if you pick
trash in math like that's on you
i i've picked trash ben you know and
i've been there
i let my ex-boyfriend in high school hit
me and try to hit me with two cars and i
was like nah it's just
okay
[Music]
that's dumb like that's trashy on me for
like staying in that situation
but like my trashiness affected him and
he infected me
right but that's what that's what i say
why i don't like matter trash because i
think it like puts all the blame on men
and women just like i'm not trying to
take money i'm not trying to deal with
this [ __ ]
in my life if i date someone like poorly
and i continue to date them
like i feel like that's on me yeah i
guess it's not no it is on you after a
certain point we're gonna talk about
how you've gotten money from freaking
men
how i survived college maddie's always
been like my crazy cousin
it would amaze me because in college she
was just getting all this money
from old guys and i'd just be sitting
there like why am i working
there is a point where like and you said
you probably made
like upwards of like 30 thousand
probably realistically like over
like a couple of years i mean there were
times where i've made five grand in a
night
those times where i made 126 yesterday
right before i got
on the airplane it's just like little
things or like there's gifts guys will
send you
and like this is a time remember when i
started college
that's when cash out came out cash shop
had just come out because they did that
that promotion where you do like the
five dollar thing but now it's 15
so get you 15 if you know from without
catching up that was just now a thing
see
men especially older men who don't know
how to use technology as well and they
just want this young girl to come to
their house because
usually they're super creepy and they'll
say like super inappropriate things
and like the second a man says something
like that to me i don't care anymore i'm
i'm gonna
screw you over like you're a disgusting
person maybe this will teach you a
lesson
and yeah that's i'm gonna get back karma
for that don't get me wrong um
so can you find more detail like what
happen oh yeah
you would get tender yes you get tinder
or a bumble or hinge really anything
and then you can say your age range you
can set your location range
and so it's like say i was going to
chicago for a weekend it's like
i would set that age range everywhere
i'm swiping on everybody
between the ages of 40 and 65 plus okay
and your intention
uh was to get money from them yeah or
like sometimes it's like funny to just
do what the [ __ ] they're gonna say
okay like because they would be like
usually pretty like disgusting like
right off the bat
i know with that age range like why but
i mean if you're that old and you're on
tinder there's a reason
would you have your cash up like in your
bio now you guys have the fastest way to
get banned
what you do is you play your you put
your snapchat
or you could be a lot of girls there
used to do like
five dollars whatever but i actually had
i ran a little like a girl cake
and i ran this little girl gang of girls
who were in relationships
and their boyfriends were like well you
can because you have to have a phone
number for tinder
and it's really easy to get your account
banned so one of my phone numbers got
banned you can't use
now numbers there's like a lot of tinder
is pretty good so what i did was i got
girls who are in
very committed relationships right out
of college first from
man that's their husband they don't need
they don't need gender they're never
going to need gender they're never going
to need it
so i had them make a profile as me use
different pictures on all the different
profiles
everybody swiped then they would send me
whenever they got the guy like talking
to them or whatever just like casually
nothing inappropriate
they would send them my snapchat when
that dude was snapchat me i'd put their
name
in my in my phone and they put like
whatever the letter of the girl who sent
me them as a first name
and then i'd be talking or whatever and
depending on the dude's five like
sometimes they'll tell you that they
want to give you money they want to buy
you stuff sometimes they'll be like
come to my house and you can be like
well i have a child
can i get a babysitter for tonight
there's a hundred and twenty dollars
um i need money for gas i would need
this this and then
basically like you would just give them
an excuse for why you needed money
yeah or they would offer it a lot of
times too like the tips are creepy
yeah or they'll be like come be my sugar
baby come do this and then you'd be like
okay prove it
send 50 bucks to prove that you're like
legit once you get it would you do
anything or give them anything or would
you just walk
there was a time when i would send out a
lot of nudes and i even still make
content
a little bit like like different videos
and stuff like on only fans i do now a
little bit
but like the amount of money you make on
only fans is so highly taxed and they
take 20
off the top already that it just makes
more sense to do it
on like a smaller scale like with just
people on my snapchat
but i've built up a clientele too like
if a dude tells you he wants a video of
you
licking your big toe and he'll send you
500 you click your big toe like
and like you know that that person's
already willing to pay
for content so you can keep that you
don't necessarily have to
get rid of them but if a dude wants you
to come to his house at three o'clock in
the morning
that dude's [ __ ] creepy right take
his money and run baby take it take get
that bag
is your boyfriend cool with this
absolutely gets less [ __ ] he has to pay
for it
he thinks it's funny i bought him a
freaking new comforter at one point
he gets new sheets guys would send me
like like lingerie and stuff
take like three photos in he's like
that's like eighty dollars
i was like yeah dude were there like
repercussions for that do you feel like
do you regret any of it are you legit
sometimes i mean i needed to do it like
i was
making i mean you know like seven
dollars an hour and i couldn't work
full-time in college because i was doing
17 hours
i mean i failed out of college cheers
because like i was [ __ ] around too
much but
ultimately that was really just burning
like it was pretty manageable
you do or you do because you said like i
know you were broke but i mean if you
could go back
i still do it though like right so like
how i can't
go back from you can't say like well
it's it's one thing though when you've
already done it to do it again
i mean i think you know what i you know
i was doing honestly i was doing it
under age
my
and my parents were really strict and
they would take my phone
so i'll just feel like [ __ ] you and i
would just i needed money because my
parents like wouldn't let me have a car
and arguably i wasn't that bad of a kid
they were really strict and like
i was definitely one of those kids going
to push my boundaries
and so i would have my friend drive me
after school and then drop me off where
the bus stop goes to go get a burner
phone
all right she'd let me borrow like 100
bucks or something to get it and then i
would go on tinder and do this at like
17.
and honestly when i was 13 i was still
out i started doing camp she was like
13.
you didn't camp yeah 13 yeah
it was pretty bad oh my god i think that
i just like
discovered porn at a young age and i
just watched it how old were you when
you discovered it
probably like 12 or 13.
yeah i think that's really quite when i
was discovering the internet and i was
like never really into that
youtube like that you know like either
youtube or porn like that's really what
was out there
that long ago and i don't even know how
i really even stumbled upon
it but like i think that because i have
like daddy problems and stuff like that
and like i have like i think i have bpd
and stuff like i just have like a weird
hyper fixation
like a sexual like i'm probably an
infamous like for sure what's it what's
that
i think that's what it's called like uh
but like it's like when you're like
obsessed with sex like i if i don't have
sex like every day like i start getting
like i start like shaking wait really
yeah like i haven't had sex in a while
like
have you ever had that since you were i
don't know when it started because i
didn't have sex until i was 17. like i
i did like i wasn't but you were still
like sexual
like you don't even yeah like with
random men on the internet or like
omegle i would do like those like
they had these games that people would
set up and it'd be like you get 50
points if like you show your boob
or something like that super predatory
on women and i think that's why i
learned from a young age that men will
like
will use you for your body but it's
effective do you feel
so a lot of men in the nanosphere feel
like um
they don't have a lot of like and you're
not even asking for it but a lot of
girls in your situation that are broke
um and do that for money they don't have
a lot of sympathy for because they're
what they say is you know what you're
[ __ ] out of luck like i'm a guy
i'm broke i can't do [ __ ] oh don't send
me money there like yeah there's
i think that some girls will sit there
and like like they'll cry and be like oh
i wish i didn't you know
no like i'll pity party people like when
i'm really broke but don't get me wrong
but like
i'm not gonna if someone said no i'm not
gonna beat a dead horse i'm just gonna
go the next one
like i said i've also built up a pretty
good clientele
i didn't mean no for like um like to
send them stuff right
no i'm saying like a lot of guys like
they would probably judge you pretty
hard for like 20 minutes
i'm saying like um like so when you say
like i don't have
money like i did this because i didn't
have money a lot like i also just wanted
more
right so a lot of men will be like so
what like but it's effective
there's other men out there that are
doing it and that the only way i know
that if you are doing it or not is if i
tell you i'm doing it
right and like right like i genuinely
believe and i'm sorry to my boyfriend
like my boyfriend likes this [ __ ]
he likes doing it like like my boyfriend
like i feel like i don't think
that he thinks he gets off from doing it
but like say my best friend comes in
town right
he pays for all of our [ __ ] okay so like
she's just pretty and like
like i don't know like we're also really
close like we hold hands like cuddle and
stuff like she'll sleep in the bed with
me
and he'll leave like he could stay in
the bed but like like that's my best
friend like we're really close like that
and like she was doing it with me at the
time at one point
and so like or like she's also we're
very different body types like i'm a
bigger girl
which like it's weird that i lowkey
would make more money than her to me
wait so you make more money because um
the man of sphere they kind of hate fat
girls
yeah no they really do it that's another
reason like i don't give a [ __ ] like you
don't [ __ ] like me i don't [ __ ]
like you
like well i'm not i'm just like like
this is just what i'm like gathering
yeah
um so they would that's really
surprising yeah i make a lot more money
i mean she's also made more money
in certain situations too like it does
change but once you
once you find the dude who's in every
everything is a cake
okay like everything squishing balloons
is a king popping balloons and fondling
balloons are two different kinks
and really you can make so much [ __ ]
money making a video
of you rubbing a balloon on your day do
you feel like um
that's gonna run out at some point
because they think
you're going to live until you're 85 or
80. sure like i can't i don't think i
can sustain myself on doing this forever
but there's gonna be a point where i
will have a different i have a job
i work i'm not just like a sugar baby
living off someone else
right but regardless if it was to get to
that point people who are professional
sugar babies they
marry those guys and they marry with the
intention
not that he'll die but that she's taken
care of forever
so uh like my boyfriend will take care
of me like
people will be like oh you manipulate
your boyfriend no i ask him for stuff
and he
is willing to like more than willing to
do it like right but it
like it goes down to like that loyal to
him too yeah
like i mean you do the stuff online he
knows though like i am 100 open you can
always
look at it if you want to uh when we
first started dating i actually had
stopped doing it for three months
because i didn't want to have him feel
like he's blindsided by
someone that's doing it but i told him
like i was like look this is something
i'm going to start back up again i want
you to know i haven't been doing it
this is something to do if you're not
comfortable with that maybe this isn't
like a relationship that
we should all be in right because this
is something that i'm good at
and that people like from me like people
like my content like
like i said i've had people on my
snapchat for four years now
who will sign up i'll post it i'll post
a picture and i'll be like like yeah
i'll show you all the picture i pictures
what do you i was gonna ask do you think
there's anything your parents could have
done to like prevent this
could not be a straight for sure like is
do you think being a strict actually led
you to do it more
i think the fact that i didn't have any
money and you get really desperate and i
feel like i said i think i
like borderline personality disorder and
so i think that feeds into it a lot
because i have a lot of like
i have a lot of like messed up thoughts
a lot like i'll think
like really depressive things and like i
i don't know my brain is like
i don't feel like it works the same way
as other people like the critical
thinking doesn't go
it goes what's going to make us like i
need 400 dollars what's the solution
what's that
because like i have a job like i said
like i've always had a job maybe
maybe like there's been times where i
quit my job because something happened
or like
you know but it's never i've never not
had a job for like
two or three months it actually um i was
surprised when i first grew i first
found out you're doing that because
i consider you like i know you're smart
and i know you work hard
yeah so i don't know i always but if i
didn't work out i wouldn't make the
money i do on here
right is this like this picture
i don't know if y'all can really let me
see oh my brightness is all the way up
but like it's really not provocative
because we have fuzzies
i look good it's kind of a catfish i
look cute though like
yeah that's hot like i don't know what
to say and like but like
some guys like really tiny skinny girls
most guys who like tiny skinny girls
are kind of misogynistic about like
that's i'm not that you can't like those
but that's like you're like a very
stereotypical dude like i don't want
your money
that's not my demographic yeah you
there's how many porn stars right like
think about it i'm not that i'm a porn
star
but like if you there's so many
different points
somebody's watching it just because it's
not for you doesn't mean it's for you to
judge
you don't want us to charge your [ __ ]
lego star wars collection but here you
are
like you know what i mean like like if i
ask you for money and you say no like
and i always you don't want to do it
just don't send it to me it's that easy
well i always say that um if guys are
because um a lot of guys are like
they're disgusted by like this stuff
right because they don't want to do it
all right
but this is what i'm saying i always say
like but they also fund it
yeah like you wouldn't do it if they
didn't fund it yeah like someone's
someone it's a it's a market for
somebody so why are you bad
that's like saying that it's disgusting
to eat ass people are eating ass
you're mad for what sorry you don't have
to get your ass i ate like
yeah you don't have to eat us this is a
choice like
like you're not gay like you don't want
to suck dick whatever like
don't not that being gay is a choice or
nothing but like
you if you want to suck that you can
it's all a choice if i want to have
someone for money
i can i just think
somebody wants to give it to you or else
they wouldn't have it like yeah there's
someone who i'll be like yeah i'll come
over
if you send me gas money but usually
when that gets to that situation
it's literally because that dude has
been harassing me for months or like
being a douche i will milk you for your
money if you have been [ __ ] annoying
to me because in my
you're paying for my time right time is
money like if you send me 43 texts a day
i'm getting 300 out of you one way or
another
but like you also have to know like the
social cues like when someone's
pretending to be nice to you you could
tell
right like oh like damn that's crazy if
you get the text no one cares what you
have to say like
you think um your parents i was just
curious because i think a lot of them
like have kids and like
i don't i don't think my parents had
anything to do with i mean my dad
i was abused pretty young too but like
it was just like a lot of little things
my parents were super young
yeah my parents my mom was a workaholic
i don't know that's a bad thing
she's really hard working and she she
busts her butt for what she has
um my dad i don't like even talk to him
anymore
he's just like not the kind of dude i
want to be around
at this point in my life um but
if you love your kid and you're
emotionally okay like
let your kids be emotional you can't you
cannot stunt that
regardless like working day here shows
you so much of like
you can tell whose parents hang out with
their kids and actually play with them
versus who puts them in front of a tv
and [ __ ] around
not that my parents said or didn't do
that but like that will
determine like how your kids turn out i
don't know
that this specific thing had anything to
do with that i think that
you also say like one i think that was
one of the first times that ever
happened
dude offered me money so like and that's
that's some dopamine right yeah in two
miles turn right
into west colina road making like real
money because i could never get the cam
show money i
actually uh i actually
i used a girl in high school or a girl
from
something i don't want to say with club
um i used to scroll like that oh sisters
i need to do it
so she got all the money you know is she
paying on taxes actually
so i really did it for fun
but like like being sexualized at such a
young age has a lot to do with it too
like
maybe like your kids shouldn't watch
more until you talk to them about it
and also i will say though my parents
really did shame me for it they told me
i was disgusting
and that i was a piece of [ __ ] and like
i remember my dad being
really just like instead of being like
let's discuss like why this is happening
why this is something you're wanting to
look at like like it's important isn't
that boring is very healthy like
regardless like it's an outlet it's i
like and that's too far away but like
i would say porn is a healthy thing i i
think an excess of
anything is bad right like you're
sitting there watching porn three thirty
hours
oh like every three days i'm like that's
a lot you don't need to do that
but i think it's also really healthy to
like get hormones out
like you should be comfortable with your
own body before other people are
exploring it
like all that stuff but i didn't get
that i was just told like i was
disgusting
but it was still something i was
interested in you feel like if your
parents
had like had a conversation earlier with
you you think you might not have done
the same thing
well i think if they had reacted
differently to
finding information out that they didn't
want to know okay
because like if you tell a kid not to do
something
that kid wants to do that a little more
instead
of left side there like like just
because my parents that they embarrass
me like
i also as a child feel embarrassed all
the time
because like my mom who doesn't really
believe in
mental illness as much um and i
definitely was like use the right lane
to turn onto west galena road it's like
like an anxiety-ridden child already
like
like i still get stomach aches from like
having to have conversations and i'm a
super social person
okay um i don't know it's just like
don't shame your kids like
if you wouldn't want to be ashamed for
something you're doing in 14 miles
take a slight left turn onto burnett
avenue
see it's funny because sometimes i wish
my parents were a little stricter
really yeah like i wish my parents um
i don't know like yeah sometimes i wish
my parents were a little like because
they kind of let us do whatever we
wanted
i wasn't allowed to have a sleepover
until i was 18. i wasn't allowed to have
soda until i was 18. sweet tea when i
had caffeine when i think about it you
know a lot of that's to prevent you from
being abused by like a dad or something
you know what i mean
but i was abused by my own dad like what
do you want me like
i was abused at home with a dad with a
heavy heavy heavy drug problem
right and then like and then like i had
a back and forth
and then my mom got married right away
right well which goes back to um
picking the right guy you know yeah but
like
because you know all of the like a lot
of these problems probably would have
been avoided if
you just picked the right guy yeah but
then i wouldn't be alive so a lot of my
problems would have been heavy avoided
but true i also think that there's a way
like once you're in a situation you just
have to handle the situation
that not every situation is just like
black and white like
sometimes i feel like when like with my
vpd i do see it and very much a black
and white like
i need a money solution problem solution
but like most things aren't like that
like there's so many different sides so
many different perspectives
like most people do things for a reason
or
even if they don't like there's an
underlying thing they don't know and
like at 12
when you're watching like really crazy
[ __ ] like doing crazy something
probably for attention like if you think
about it right because like why else
would i want some stupid points on an
omegle thing well you probably weren't
getting
a little dope well you probably weren't
getting the right attention from your
dad
exactly or my mom like because you know
like they were fighting and they were
trying to get divorced or they
at that point maybe were divorced even
but then like my dad was in prison
and like i'm living he went to prison
for
um he was supposed to go to prison for
me but they gave him like probation
or something like that and then he drunk
drove and smashed into a bunch of cars
will they get an ankle bracelet on sorry
i'm exposing you
um i don't feel bad please stop texting
me um
but also yeah and then he snatched the
car and then he went to prison
but he also was a master manipulator and
he still does it to aiden
which really upsets me on my own but he
got me
a guinea pig before he left like
literally not long
like maybe in two months he knew he was
going to jail i didn't know
and my mom knew and he told it and she
said not to get one because she i wasn't
bringing it back to her house
but in the end all that happened was my
dad went to jail and i lost my guinea
pigs my mom wasn't taking the giving she
already had said that
right but not to me it's my dad who
still got it so then like
i was like double upset like i don't
know it's just like little things like
none of the guinea pig really matters
it's just the fact that
when you're at that age and you're
already trying to figure out who you are
you're just stressed all the time and
like
that you're not getting any attention
like you feel like everyone's against
you
everyone's leaving you everyone's
abandoning you like you don't really
have a
foot to stand on were you in daycare
um i think i went to a preschool
i don't think i ever really went to
daycare i know my grandma watched me i
used to
work at my you know like uncle i'm not
gonna say but like
the office we used to i used to hang out
there a lot and my grandma
who at the time was a really heavy
alcoholic would watch me
okay yeah so i mean i still got
attention but it was you know so if you
if you had like a daughter would you
want her like would you
encourage her to go the same route you
did or would you say like like avoid
that i mean i would encourage her to
know what her passion is because like
personally i don't have one
so i'm not really at this moment in time
i'm surviving in life like i'm not
necessarily working for a specific
thing or like like there's a couple of
things i might
consider pursuing but none that i'm like
overly passionate about like this is my
dream this is what i want to do like
i'm good at this but again that could be
my mental illness you know
so it's like i don't know i if she
wanted to do it
get that bag says i guess but like
there's a lot of consequences it's not
just like getting money like
yeah people are crazy like people have
stalked me before
like um but i've also had people be like
really discreet and like i blackmailed
people for it
there was one time this guy in texarkana
actually
me and my my friend actually we had both
saw him on this
um it's like a fetish website it's
called fetlife
um it's not for like making money it's
for people finding
people with the same kinks and stuff um
it's actually pretty cool so if you like
specific king like and you don't know a
lot of people within you want to see
that community
it's kind of good to go explore see what
people have but there's a lot of guys on
there who like
cage up their penises for like
that term and they put spikes in them
and stuff those like i've got a
dominatrix like that's kind of
like i've gotten to step on a man's bp
and tell him he's a small dick little
[ __ ]
and then him can hand me money like
that's that's a power play like what
what that's some dopamine right there
like you will never feel better in your
life than having a stiletto
on a man's nut stack like i don't know i
like that i've never had a better rush
not my boyfriend not my boyfriend i
can't get that
gentleman do you want me to show you
pictures no no i have a bunch of
men in a cage for me please don't don't
there's guys you do that in person like
um i have before most of the time i do
online dominating tricks especially with
kobe that was easy
um but like i had a man who would lock
himself in a dog kennel for five hours a
day and wear a collar with my neighbor
and his neck
and send me money to do it so like
it's hard to say no to that because like
that's appealing like i want
you to be in pain because you're i don't
know it's pretty easy for me but they
love it but they want that
and they'll be like i'll send you money
for that yeah for me to do nothing
for me to humiliate you yes let me get
my hanger out on somebody because
it's not it's gonna be like offered like
okay so i've been offered money
like for my leggings before okay and i
turned it down why
because i don't want to clone you look
as [ __ ] no people look like your world
no i just like felt weird i feel like i
saw my panties
i felt so weird knowing that that guy
was gonna like jackal like ah i just
didn't like so they could still jack off
to you on this youtube channel i mean
i'm sure somebody is right now
yeah i know i know but at least you know
where it is
yeah i just honestly think about how
many leggings you throw out
why would you not make a hundred bucks
off that you could make i don't know i
did
you wanna wanted to wear a pair of
panties for two days just two days you
know like
people will pay double the amount of
money
i have sold a pair of panties for like
eighty seven dollars for
a walmart pair of panties that's so
crazy
and you can like vacuum what type of
guys are these so are they
like is it men not dudes i want to meet
[ __ ] real no i'm saying like um
the dominatrix stuff so all different
kinds when i think of these guys i'm
thinking of like
weird weird guys that don't have social
skills
but don't ever want to let me tell you
the story about savannah um this dude we
didn't
dominate him really but he um we did
emotionally dominate him
so he was actually we found out his name
like
because we're fbi agents like oh i just
want water all over myself i'm an idiot
um
so and this dude messages me in there
on the same website separate things um
uses the same fake name
uh it was obviously fake it was like
john smith or something like that
but it was like when sweden you used um
kik you know that message just like that
everyone used to use in like middle
school
that's just still exciting i never used
that but well
kick me later um so what happened
so he was like i want to give you money
y'all you're beautiful but he's talking
to both of us at the same time and we
didn't ever tell him we were we knew
each other like
so he would be like you're the only girl
i'm ever talking to i want to give you
in my whole life
my whole love like oh blah blah blah
just be bs
well we ended up finding out his name he
owns a very
very popular company in texas canada and
um
so he was rich yeah like super rich he
had a wife kid
but he would go around texas canada
because he didn't want to deposit it or
send it over
like money money and i'm not letting
them i i did eventually then
down to my house but i never met him uh
he would leave money like around a place
like a scavenger hunt
over texas canada there'd be a salon
that we would go to and he would leave
an envelope with our name under the mat
be like a grand or like whatever we
needed like
oh i need some textbooks i wasn't even
in school they had some textbooks
send a little picture with some cleavage
and like a little like put your lashes
on like
cross your legs with your hands please
and we would take the pictures from each
other we would literally
take each other's news to send to this
dude and only like five for like a grand
like that's
that's [ __ ] nothing because like the
amount of dude nudes that i sent out
like in high school and stuff like
i mean like i guess that's technically
but i was like to people my age and
stuff like you know
i don't know you don't care at some
point you're like i'm a very open person
like
yesterday i was showering my aunt was
sitting there talking to me like i don't
care like i'm i'm
very comfortable with myself like that
even if i'm not like fully confident
like
sexually like like with my body like i'm
i don't think it was able to see my boob
like
these aren't sexual they're just always
in my space you know like they're in the
way
but he would do that for both of us and
eventually i got so lazy i don't feel
like driving around anymore
that i said i sent him a picture of his
wife and so he would just leave money in
my mailbox
but he would never go in because he'd be
too scared i'd [ __ ] tell his wife
oh but then he would still do it for him
we would do it and we make double the
amount of money
she basically now but so yeah that
happened a lot that was that was like
one time we made so much money off that
guy
there was another dude at one time he
would drive down because he wanted to
give
we told rachel we took rachel's tire off
her guard and put my attire that popped
onto hers
took a picture yeah i know how to change
tire well only for that i just get
confused because
on one hand you'll say like i can't eat
i'm barely scraping by
and then you'll it's just like it's it's
like it's like
and then you'll say like oh i got a
thousand dollars so do you just like
spend
it right away yeah well like i said i
used to have a
[Applause]
copious addiction at one point in my
life and so like that
didn't take a lot of money but now i'm
not really doing anything big scale
like i said i have my boyfriend and like
he takes care of me pretty well and i
work
at daycare now and so it gets me
not nervous but it's like a kind of a
public image thing especially i live in
a smaller town
right in texas um and so it's like
like it doesn't really matter they find
out i make eight dollars an hour they're
like you know
but i'm not trying to accidentally be
talking about the kids dads
and especially with kova we don't see
the parents as much right but they saw
me one time they would know who it is
you know what i mean like if if it
happened or if it's like someone's
husband like i'm not trying to get
jumped at the walmart like
i chill out a lot more well the other
thing i get confused about and a lot of
like they talk about this in the
menosphere how girls will say they hate
men but men [ __ ] your entire like
i mean i don't i all men i also hate
most men's tendencies but i don't
these men i don't really deal with in
any more of a context of sexual
okay or into them sexual
rights or i get hit on all day long and
like yeah
i need it for my money but it's like
going to your work don't you hate your
job sometimes
yeah everyone hates their job but you
still go
and you still go to work just like you
got to right so
so you look at it as like hating your
boss yeah
basically i mean somebody like it's
different than dating
so the dating men like
are way different than my client telling
me they're in two different worlds to me
i don't i would never ever ever and i'm
sorry if you're on my snapchat
date you if you're on my private store
my boyfriend's not even on my private
story anymore wait
um so how has dating been with like so
you've been doing this stuff since you
were like
12 13. yeah i definitely stopped though
because my mom was crazy um she was
started
fair enough right so in and out yeah
since you were 12 30. probably more
since i turned 18 my mom kicks me out
and i was homeless for a while
so that was really where it peaked
though because um
my baby peaked but got me really back
and started into it and put me on
different platforms
and like i said like a thousand dollars
like yeah that's a lot of money but
not if because there was a point like i
said i was homeless like
i had to pay for so much stuff and then
i had to furnish a house and then like
it's expensive to live and then like
when you're doing that stuff sometimes
you are driving out sometimes you are
buying lingerie for your photos
you are spending money on your hair you
have to spend money on your makeup do
you feel like if you had money you
wouldn't have done this stuff
like if um your mom was paying for your
school
i don't know i think that if my mom paid
for my school fully i probably still
would have party too much and gotten
kicked out
just because of my grades to be honest
so like it's not
i mean i don't know i always knew that
there wasn't enough money for me to go
to school too right
so i don't want to say one way or the
other because like now i would go back
to school
right but like stuff always happens to
like
i don't know like that attention
definitely became like a part of it
but you also get like it's like a rush
like
i i love making like i love seeing my
bank account get bigger so
you you kind of did it for the
adrenaline rush more
it sounds like you you did it i feel
like yeah it's like little and it's like
dopamine on some level too like so
you're having a shitty day and then
someone buys you new shoes like that's
a good feeling it's like small things
too
and like also when it comes to that i
try to level out my karma as much as i
could so i would try to like
like say i got i just paid a grand i'm
gonna go spend like 400
with me and my girls like we're gonna go
have a good time with this because i'm
gonna treat them good or buy
say buy homeless people some food like
not always a lot
like i would try to do small things like
that to level up
karma like you know you think you'll get
like bad
do you look at this as wrong sometimes
because sometimes they think you're
coming i'm not coming i'm never trying
to eat
realistically oh like there are
different times too like
like something like i said if the dude
is annoying me and he's offering to send
me money to come over i'm not coming up
right to a boyfriend so you're not gonna
one yeah two
um you're probably really creepy and
probably going to skip
me skim you yeah like people are great
like have you ever been in a situation
where you thought you were going to die
no i'm pretty safe like i always have
friends that either
like sometimes i go out to restaurants
i'm not opposed to a free meal don't get
me wrong yeah i even apple
i can [ __ ] up some applebee's like when
i actually worked at applebee's i would
have all my sugar daddy dates
at applebee's that's another way people
make money um
like you go up there and i play you
better tip the waitress and i would take
the thing except for 50
and then he would leave me like 100
bucks just having dinner
but sometimes they think that you're
gonna have multiple dinners with them
but if i don't like you like that and i
don't think you're a good sugar daddy
that i won't
have you ever had like feelings for a
sugar daddy no
do you feel like because you've been
doing this since you were 18.
do you think it got in the way of like
potential dating prospects at all
um now because in college i was obsessed
with this guy
who told me about like he's not into me
like that we just hooked up for a year
right and like he actually ended up
dating like one of my best friends and
they like just broke up finally
well do you think like possibly that was
why did he know about that oh you know
about it but he
profited off of it like i would go buy
like like use a frat so i would go buy
the whole front a bunch of pizzas
i know guys will profit off of it but
that doesn't mean they like respect you
know
i mean honestly i know that he he thinks
it's funny like
honestly a lot of my friends like a game
like how much money how much money can
maddy make if it comes down to the wire
like uh and you know like sometimes
you're really up in money and sometimes
you're not that's just also
life like sometimes you buy [ __ ] you
need like or sometimes your car really
does
like need new tires or like stuff like
that and that's 400
or like sometimes you get a ticket that
costs you more than you know a
ballpark 1400 at the stop sign not tower
down to east main street
no i mean i hear what you're saying it
just like
it really sounds like he was just using
you like for like the entertainment
oh no we're still like good friends to
this day actually okay
no no no i mean he definitely we were
just hooking up he definitely made that
very clear
that he did not have feelings for me
like from the get-go that was me like i
just
i became like overly indian but like
we're still like i guess he's probably
one of my best friends actually
like definitely a top three your
boyfriend's cool my boyfriend loves him
because like i don't know like i could
go cuddle with this dude and like play
with his hair in bed
but it would not be sexual at all and i
don't know i understand that in a lot of
different ways and a lot of different
people it would be still
this too and i are just not on like a
weird platonic level but he definitely
meant like we definitely
we definitely let's do that like we go
to dinner
because i don't like certainly when
people work for their money like work
harder like i feel
bad like if we all go out and i'm doing
something easy to make money like
i want to share that with y'all right so
that was a big plot honestly if i had
saved a lot more money
i'd probably be that's that's what i was
thinking like it's hard to save money
when you're in that mindset because when
i don't need money i'm not trying to
make money
oh really i'm i get lazy about it
i like my money on like food but that's
it but i'll see you know thousand
dollars really isn't that much money
i was going to like i said like at the
daycare i make like a
ten dollars a check maybe my rent's 400
right so if i want to eat and my bills
you know like summertime in texas like
my bills are probably 200 and then i
have a 200 car payment
125 interest there's already negative
money there like
continue on to highway 78 a 40-hour job
wait so um three hours a week another
question so do you feel like
it doesn't sound like you've really had
any repercussions from because
it like i'm not a cop i've had stock i
got that people trying to stalk me but
then like you can tell when a new
account adds you right after you just
block somebody
right you don't want to deal with them
like well i just mean like long term
like it doesn't
assuming you get married to your
boyfriend you still get married
right yeah um your boyfriend doesn't
care i'm honest about it
if i had lied about that that would be a
big thing to like just drop on somebody
but like i said like and even if i
hadn't stopped in the little bit of our
relationship all his friends judge me
they slayed me to this day
okay but turn left onto highway w but
those are just people i don't want to be
around i don't want
to be around people who are judging me
like
okay so so there has been some you would
say
a little bit but like nothing that
really bothers me because that's not the
reason they didn't like me right
that's just what they told like his
parents and stuff and guess what like
his mom
still likes me because i'm still a good
person right
like in 3.7 miles keep
like do different things than you like
it's like essentially being mad at
strippers like
i basically am a personal stripper right
i have a very specific niche platform
for what i do
and i've built it over years like i said
like if i need money i can
make a little bit here and there yeah no
i hear you i'm just wondering because
they talk a lot about like the
repercussions later on for like being on
these platforms
only fans it will get you i will say
that which
like like my job brought it up to me
when i went to the daycare they're like
what is this and i was like oh well you
know like
only fans but i'm an adult and my page
is private
i don't have a free open page to anyone
um and i don't really use it anymore
blah blah blah
but honestly like we're moving past an
age in this culture where
that stuff is gonna matter i think just
like you know like having colored hair
and tattoos is becoming more and more
normal
like piercings like you're gonna come to
a point where like
sex work is real work like so like i
said someone's paying for it
right like just because you don't like
it then you don't have to like see
i actually think that women are gonna
end up single
honestly for you it's worked out but i
i've seen a lot of girls get like turned
down
because that's not a do they want to be
with anyway i know but a lot of guys are
cool with that
that's cool make a generation that's
more accepting
be single honestly like there's so many
more benefits to being single
or go date one of the dudes into it
because clearly there's a lot of dudes
into it
because there's enough girls making
money that there are dudes into it
i don't really care about brad and chad
wearing the [ __ ] patagonia
with their cut off like cargo khaki
shorts
honestly like they don't [ __ ] themselves
like i don't know like
i don't i don't care for those types of
people and the people i care about
i've made content with right you know
like
i'm gonna make out with one of my
friends for a video and make 400 bucks
in two miles keep right down to highway
p you know like i can go out and have a
fun night with my girlfriend
like and have no essentially no spending
limit
and just have a good time and maybe
that's not something you're interested
in doing
right but like that's something i wanted
to go out and do and i've
solved my problem and i didn't have to
save up for five months
to make that happen on money i don't
even have to save that like yeah
arguably i can go find a different job
and go make more money but that comes
with a lot of different things like i
have
i have holidays off like i can be here
right now yeah i can
have my weekends off i'm off by six
o'clock every day i also
dash like yeah i work i work a lot no i
know
i've always known you're a hard worker
yeah i'm never going to discount no i
don't think that you
i just like i just think it would be
unwise
to tell someone like for for me and this
is coming from someone who hasn't done
it yeah
to say there are no repercussions i
don't think there's none like
there's definitely like i said like i've
seen people in public who've known me
like like i said like the parents like
they could they could see me like right
that's why i do it on a smaller scale
now
like i said like dad found my pornhub
one time
that was embarrassing and i also don't
like necessarily
think it's wrong for a guy to not want
his like girlfriend to be doing
no and it's not that's why i was honest
with my boyfriend but like i had
something i'm interested in doing
that's not it's not necessarily a deal
breaker but like that i'm telling you up
front like
that's not a girl you won't want to be
with and don't be with her well and
that's
a girl who didn't do it or go do it
yourself or go make a couples page
go have fun go make that bad because
somebody wants to see it okay what
percentage of men do you think are
sexually active that are single
i have no idea keep right down to
highway
um what defines sexually acting in
like having sex like not like like
in the last three months or within like
either convergence or have ever had sex
i don't know
because i feel like that matters because
like because i
would say that some people will consider
themselves sexually active but still not
be having sex for
a couple of months just because they
don't have a consistent partner okay
let's just say or like is it and after
your virgin are you considered sexually
active
i don't know these are questions i never
asked
let's get i'm gonna just guess in the
last three months
okay um i would say i would say it's
probably pretty high i mean with covet i
would assume it went down
i know in texas it probably didn't
because i'm really locked up
but like i would say
knowing that i live with two guys they
probably one of them probably gets laid
like
every three weeks and probably the other
one probably it's like at least every
two weeks
let's go 75 um so the amount of guys
that are sexually active
is 20 20 yeah 80
of single men are sexually inactive and
it's actually because of something
called the prado principle have you
heard of that
no never so 20 of the people in the
world
maybe last but like 20 or less own 80
of the wealth 20 of the people in the
nba score 80
of the points does that make sense
yeah and it's the same thing in dating
so the reason that a lot of women
hate men is because they're literally
dating the same guys
and they did this study without the same
types of dudes
no literally the same one oh
so i'm saying they did this study where
one you can look at paternity
uh and you can look at it over history
so in history
only uh forty percent of men reproduced
were eighty percent of women dead so
it's two to one really
and it's the same thing with um
uh with looking at paternity today
do you think it's because like it's it's
a lot easier for women
to get with like if they want to get
laid it's a lot easier
i'd say men strike out a lot more
there's a lot of guys out there who do
like the whole pikmi thing
like that continue on to us 61. oh oh
girls what is money they never want me
but you're also the dudes who's like
being really [ __ ] in a way
well and uh there's a lot more in 7.9
miles turn left onto e street that
contribute to a girl
liking you and like yeah there are some
girls who are super like stereotypical
like [ __ ]
but you don't want to be with those
people anyway right so like like on
someone like they reject you
because of that okay [ __ ] them like you
can go find someone who likes that
well and instead of complaining that the
girls don't like you maybe improve your
social skills yeah like because there's
clearly
if it's a consistent problem there's a
common denominator you know what i mean
right and maybe it's not maybe you're
just in a wrong group of people
right but then got like if you always
are at some dive bar
maybe go to a nicer place like maybe
those are trash and girls like
i like the dive bar maybe you don't want
to hang out with me like
right well i said the same thing with
girls though if you keep picking guys
that like
exactly that's the same that's that's
you have to remember
like if you always date a dude who's a
drug dealer you're probably gonna stay
doing drugs for a long time like
like but if you start dating a banker
like you might have a house like
like this is a choice and like maybe
bankers don't like you but there is a
banker out there who would
like if you set your mind on the type of
person you want you'll get them
i have seen some of the ugliest dudes
pull models the
ugliest dudes like that's i think
do they have money though no not really
yeah no i have a
i'm not gonna make something like that
because that one one or another
but like there's like another like
different things like if you have a good
personality there's you're gonna find
the person that wants to be around you
it's not gonna matter what your face
looks like or what your body looks like
right then that's the person that you
want to be finding anyways like you
should count it as a list
like a tick off your checklist like oh
not her
bye on to the next one don't be stressed
about someone who's not trying to hang
out with you like
but um it actually makes a lot of sense
why there's so many guys that pay for
only fans and like that sort of because
it's the girls that rejected them
yeah yeah and like i know a bunch of
girls who got a bunch of money from
dudes from back in high school
actually i have dudes from high school
yeah
but yeah i have dudes from high school
that definitely cheat on their
girlfriends by asking me
for my knits and i'll send it to them
and then i'll send their girlfriend a
text it's not complicated
i respect the girl but i'm gonna get my
bag too
like will you get your bag like will you
get it a couple times before you tell
them or do you do it immediately it
depends on who the girl is if i don't
like her than this on my business that's
not my boyfriend you know
and like it's not like that's your
boyfriend's actions you can't be mad at
me
because i'm offering a service that he
decides to take up just like if
my boyfriend used to cheat like i can't
i mean some of them like
if someone directly disrespects you it's
different but like
i can't like on only fans i don't
control who subscribes there's a button
like
yeah they on there when i notice i
notice what do you think a girl should
bring to the table
in terms of uh in a relationship feels
loaded
um i think it just depends on the
relationship well like
everyone's needs are different i need a
lot of more emotional help than anything
else
no i'm not like what do what are you
like what would you bring to like your
boyfriend
one time i brought him a sandwich i
don't i'm lost
no um so you know like
so they ask a lot of times like what do
you bring to the table outside of just
sex
oh cause they can get sex anywhere so
what do you bring to the relationship
i'm hilarious um i know like yesterday i
was yelling at him
i don't know how to answer this question
different way but i like we were
he was just a calling or something i was
like you're so [ __ ] annoying whatever
and then you text me and i was like
thank you for kidding me out of my
depression like i love you
and i was like yeah i did that like
that's that's why i don't know like i
guess i just
i do it for him i don't know like
there's like an emotional connection
that we have
that like me literally being upset and
like scrunching my nose at him like
he was like oh i feel all the way better
so i don't know i'm a very weird person
though so i don't
i'm funny i don't i don't think much so
so
in order to retire by 65 how much money
do you think you need
it's like a million dollars if you'd
like to be 85
20 years man i'm not trying to live past
30 years
i'm not going to hide unless i got kids
and then i'm living until
to lay out the house so knowing that
information do you feel like women need
that
no i mean you can still make money
without men i mean i mean
obviously i picked a route where i
choose to use that
but there's i mean i could be selling
pictures to women too
i have like women still buy into this
product as well and then like
and otherwise you can save money and
make money with like roth iras and stuff
like it's a choice in one mile turn left
onto e street
like i probably could have money up set
up an off roth ira and be a lot better
set up than even my boyfriend is right
now
if i had chosen to do so do you think
it's better for women to get married
before 30
do you think their options start to run
out after 30. maybe not the options but
you it comes into a lot of like
difficulty having children so like yeah
if you really want kids
a lot of dudes like will say they don't
want kids and then they end up wanting
kids
right so like there's that's a big issue
because like once you hit a certain
point
the amount of kids you can have is gonna
be a lot lower
um and then you also run into the fact
that you're getting to the age where
there's a lot of divorce people
and there's a lot of people who are
divorced forever there's a lot of shitty
people well in the mana sphere they seem
to think
um it's very much completely over for
women if they wait till after 35.
it's like [ __ ] up um it's like ages
like so men shouldn't get married you
shouldn't jerk off yeah
is um no this is what they say okay this
is something interesting i never thought
about
so do you know what like sexual sexual
marketplace value is
i actually don't turn left down to east
street i wouldn't either it feels like
something i should know so like
no yeah i didn't either it's a very like
weird kind of weird term um
so it basically what it refers to is it
refers to
what you're worth basically on the
market so on the dating market
okay so they look at they looked at the
things that
men value and women value for 19 miles
continue straight past like a ton of men
and like they basically gave people
enough surveys
what surveys we know it's not like
they're like famous shoes like
yeah each thing has like a different
i don't watch family feud oh my god i
don't think um
does that make sense though yeah because
like at the end of different things
they're different
points like different values right so
i mean i think because at the end of the
day it's like supply and demand right
that that
determines like your value but didn't
you say that it's like 80
like women are still getting laid more
so yes so women kind of still have more
options
yeah they they do oh yes they would
totally agree
they say the options of the men that
they want
run out after 35 so they don't get it
yeah because there's a lot of the top of
them
i do not want money what else one of the
if you don't get one of like
your best option when you're young then
you're gonna have to like settle so to
speak
but there's a lot of like everyone
thinks everyone on the twenties
are like everyone in their 20s is stupid
so like you you want someone to pick
someone to be with no um so this is this
is what they said though like
men want fit feminine friendly that's it
they just want a girl it's nice
thinner than them usually um
nice and and feminine
so like motherly i mean that's just like
kind of put a woman in this really
specific box
too though it doesn't mean everyone i
just said like that's the that's like
that's what the you can't you can't
argue with like what they said that is
statistics
and so women what they value changed
over time so under the age of like 22 or
23
it's just looks like i want a cute guy
so then they get a little older and
social just like social amends don't
change
what do you mean like the men's didn't
change over time at all
no like 10 like men tend to want young
women
like all across not not every single no
i know about you i'm saying like that
like fit feminine friendly and young
younger than that
right so and that and women um
it was like basically like social status
so like a guy being funny popular
whatever um
[Music]
their job obviously career success
um and how they look so hype looks
so the older a woman gets the less she
values looks so that's why you see like
ugly guys like pole models
yeah but that's good but like but men
don't care about women's money
at all they didn't rank that as
important they don't care
but i mean it is important in a lot of
aspects to your life like money
rules our economy like well not kind of
like most like everything like we're in
a consumer world
like it matters especially if you think
about how much money matters like
paying rent paying bills doing all these
little things
like maybe it shouldn't be a big factor
but it definitely should be a factor
like
on some level of thinking about
something that you want to spend your
time with if they're not go with money
then you might not well because at the
end of the day if a guy has his own
money
yeah he doesn't care about yours that's
true if he can he can manage the credit
cards
so he could put you like and most girls
if he's paying for everything they'd be
cool with that
yeah yeah like you know i mean
i feel good if you're if your boyfriend
said hey i don't want you to work i just
want you to stay at home
um raise our kids
i mean i think a man would love that a
man
like you know what i mean like if he had
that option like there are women who
would do that it's just less
likely but if more people were to do it
i'm sure it would become more popular
but see this is where i disagree because
there aren't men lined up to date oprah
but there's men
lined up to date supermodels okay but
then they're just judging a woman off
her body because like oprah
i know that's why so then isn't that
mores to say on the man
well i'm i'm i'm not saying if it's
right or wrong i'm saying what it is
i don't know i i think then that just
goes into the fact that men will pay for
like that that's what i'm saying so like
men will be mad that women profit off of
it but that's all they say they want but
no no so the question this is the
question
asking so knowing that information right
they
recommend to get married young because
you can get more while you're younger
so they say like if you want the best
like quality husband
focus on getting married and marry young
because that because
the older you get the less men will want
to date you statistically
and then maybe you're just not with the
right man i think that's okay
yeah i think he does not like i think
that's just that if
if a man if that's what like he's based
off then
like it's just not the person for you
but that sounds to me like i'm not
i don't fit into that category like i'm
not i'm fun
but like and i'm pretty and stuff but
like i'm not like a super fit small
person
but i also like i said i make a lot of
money off stuff but you're not you're
not
huge no i'm really not that so that's
what i'm saying like i just that's why i
said thinner than that
yeah my boyfriend's like really small
yeah
my wife was like 30 size jeans that's
what i've actually noticed there's a lot
of the super skinny guys like
they're going for big girls because i
can't put on weight because they're
insecure about being skinny isn't that
funny
oh everyone wants what they don't
[ __ ] have um
but i don't know i just thought it was
interesting because
i don't know it just seemed like i think
it's kind of sad
like i feel like men should put more
thought into
other aspects but i also don't think
i don't think as a woman woman you
really understand like all the privilege
like we
recognize a lot of the privileges we get
for being a girl oh i know like i know
that
if i didn't have money and i'm out to
you i could get a guy the next able to
pay for it like it wouldn't be hard
especially if
my boobs out like even a little i also
know that if i have my boobs out i
will like will have people stare at me
not that i always want that
sometimes i just like that talk or like
that outfit but you can definitely play
your strengths up but that's like like
guys can play their strengths up too
whenever
like it's just different situations like
like a guy can be funny and loud and
like boisterous and like when i'm
really loud and [ __ ] people be like oh
don't be loud that's definitely like
a problem i mean it's kind of hard
because i think what guys are attracted
to
it's hard because i'm like genuinely not
sometimes yeah like i'm a loud person
like people literally
like they're like that's a turnout i'm
not the same exactly
i'm not trying to but i'm not trying to
attract you
right i'm trying to attract someone who
is into this because i'm not trying to
change for somebody
like my woman is the quietest man i've
ever met in my life
and it makes no sense the first time i
met him my friends were like
maddie you can't talk to this dude not
not leaving like that we were like he
was fixing this dude's computer by one
of my other friends
who like one time but um he's like
they're like you can't be here
like you have to go go out with sarah
whatever like you can't be at the house
because we're all hanging out and i was
like you're so rude
and they're like no you're just you're a
lot like we don't want to like subject
into that
and then it turns out like i'm like the
person you know he loves and like that's
awesome
but it's like funny because people have
all these like expectations for other
people
to act but i think like a lot of it
comes from
people who need to be either more
accepting or just be okay with the fact
that people don't like you well yeah
i definitely think personality is part
of it but it's not amazing
but that's why i mean one year connected
was we're both funny and we're both like
kind of out there
yeah like a little goofy like yeah
weirdos you know like everyone's a
little bit weirdo
right and that's a good thing to me like
i i understand a lot of people are
superficially a lot of people want that
cookie cutter life but
i put myself in that position not to
have that you know like
i'm like i don't know i have no idea
what i'll be doing in three months
i don't even know why i'm gonna live at
the end of this month right now like
but if that should be a factor in
wanting to date me you know what i mean
like
that it shouldn't just be like oh well
she's cute unless she's skinnier than me
oh she got a bad ass like
like you know it should be like oh this
[ __ ] has none of her [ __ ] together
maybe this isn't a good option for my
life it's not that
you know it's not that they don't look
at that stuff is it starts
somewhere so they have to like what they
see to start
yeah but i think it's a good thing that
women are a little more judgy
and not not judgey judgey but like i
i feel like women definitely judge
people more i think it's
good and bad to judge people sometimes
like sometimes you see like a crackhead
you're like i'm gonna go inside like
that's a good judgment girl
i just um
i think there's a lot of girls that are
single and older and really don't
want to be and that's that i'm also 22.
so i don't really interact with people
like that
unless i'm at like a bar or something
but even then like there's always dudes
hitting on them and like
if they don't want that then like that's
they can't help it
and if you've never found something that
you want like just to settle for someone
it's
like selfish because what is that for
like that person could have found
somebody actually wanted to be like
i mean it all depends on your standards
right if their standards are
ridiculously high
they probably shouldn't but you won't be
happy if they're not meeting your
standards anyways like
you could if you lower your standards to
meet somebody else
you'll never be fully happy because you
you had that somewhere i don't think
like most women are happy and well
really
no i don't i don't like being alone but
i like being alone
when i'm hooking up and having fun with
people um
years ago i don't i don't think women
like genuinely are happy by themselves
like i think most women that are
single i don't know i don't agree with
that at all actually
i love i i have a lot of friends who
like being single how old are they
i mean i'm 22 though yeah that's right
like most of my friends are my i have
like the oldest my friend is like 27
but even none of them really want to get
married unless they've been in long-term
relationships right
but but right now they're young that's
what i'm saying like you haven't really
seen the older
like i'm 24 so i don't i don't know i i
wouldn't say people
i see i see the desperation in girls
eyes when they hit 32 33 34
and they i can just tell i think a lot
of that also has to do with the
situations that they put themselves
in like the places they're going because
like if you feel like it's in the dive
bar that's not where you're finding
that's not what you're finding
yeah i think a lot of girls go to clubs
for years and then guys
like so it's not necessarily that
they're choosing that they're like
being picky they're just choosing bad
places to go find men
no i think sometimes they make choices
that make guys not want to date them
the guys they want anyway i mean they
don't have to explode like tell people
that they do on the video they can stop
too right no one has you could delete
your account yeah
like they don't ever have to know like
you don't owe anybody your past
you if you're gonna be with someone like
i was open about it because it's
something that i felt like i wanted to
be open about
i stopped because i like genuinely like
wanted to be with them and i felt
comfortable telling them that
but like nobody else like i don't know
anybody
anything about my life if i have like an
std or something that'd be different
right but like because you owe you
should tell these people your sexual
history in regards to them right but
like your business is your business
like maybe you don't need to be putting
it all out there like you know
but like as i just did but like like
yeah i don't know
like you you could choose what to tell
people
and if people are going to judge you
then i don't i don't like to be around
for judgment i mean maybe your might
maybe that's why my circle's small but
my circle's tight like i know who has my
bag at the end of the day i'm not
i'm not worried about i can literally i
could fart in my boyfriend's mouth and
he would be like thanks
like like there's no
i wasn't a sad one but i think we've
done that um like just for funsy like i
was just messing with the worst i don't
know
anyway yeah no like like he doesn't
judge anymore he's like a good fart babe
like
that's a good feeling like people were
like oh i can't fire food for like a
month oh my god
you got too much energy to be worried
about that
but i also like i said i'm a very open
person like everyone has their own
levels of that
and like what you're comfortable with
but you should be able to be your most
authentic in 10 miles arrive at
cassville
you should always be able to be your
most authentic self with that person and
if you're not
then you need to go out and either
change where you're going your habits
whatever figure out what's going to work
for you
yeah no i agree yeah cause like i
honestly i
if i was gonna do to judge me just like
i'd be like you can go
because that's who i am like they're not
everyone's like that
but right some people are like kind of
more prissy
and stuff like that but there's also
dudes who are like that so like go find
you a man
yeah and that's actually what i think
that a lot of people the manosphere
say like it's over for all these women
but it's not necessarily over if eighty
percent of men are single
and i'm not having sex like that's what
um how are you getting mad at the girls
are you no that's why i get a little uh
frustrated not even frustrated but a lot
of the guys will say
oh if you hit 30 like it's over for you
all done
but i'm like you could date a 50 year
old and have a 20 year age gap and have
him really that like
you know look really valuable yeah like
look at you is very like young
i mean i'm sure it's harder to find but
you can pay like but with the divorce
rates it's probably really not
like i know i mean like obviously
there's always gonna be the dudes who
prey on younger women and like room 17
year olds but those dudes are creepy
anyway
like those are the dudes anyone should
be wanting to marry yeah like you should
be marrying
like the authentic goofy guy that's like
five with you
i definitely think your choices affect
things like
like i wouldn't want to go date my ex's
best friend or anything
right but yeah people get too hung up on
what they can have
yes i think that's very true they'll
give you a chance
who wants you yeah yes i'm not trying to
[ __ ] like trisha paytas
like just players don't know who i am
you know let me be like
but she know you like like guys i'm
gonna do with me like why am i i'm upset
like i could see your mia like oh just
your face don't follow me
that's so sad oh but she follows my
cousin i can sit here and say
my entire day being so pissed off about
it yes yes
or i could be like but damn i i just
watched other [ __ ] that's what a lot of
girls do so they get mad at what they
can't help and then they're focused on
that instead of going out and getting
something else
so instead it's like it's not it's
you're not allocating your time
correctly
right you're not using like the time
that you have you're buying yourself a
pity party
and then same with the men it's over for
you at 30 because i don't want to like
ugh just go you want your dick sucked go
get a sucker
don't like shut the [ __ ] up go find a
[ __ ] who wants that
that's it have i have some standards
because they matter but i don't feel
like people beat on you
but like and if they are like yeah you
it's gonna be hard to leave and [ __ ] but
like that's not the person for you
that's not
that's not it and it's like there is no
that's it until you're dead
and you're not even gonna have to deal
with it at that point so
and like if you make a shake choice
everyone makes you choices
everyone and their [ __ ] they don't want
to tell you everyone's doing some crack
ass [ __ ] they don't want to tell you
that's true everybody and it'll come out
one day yeah i'm gonna
find out and be like whoa do you really
don't think you out
you don't owe someone you shouldn't tell
someone you're dating that you used to
have an only fan
i still think it's our business that's
like that's like why do i have to give
some of my entire sexual history well i
just think it's
it's something if he's choosing like the
mother of his kids i think that's like a
fair
thing to say i don't want a wife who's
done anything i think if he expressly
tells you that that's something he
wouldn't want
yeah then you need to leave that
situation if you're not comfortable
telling him
okay but like he has to come up to you
and be like oh i would hate a [ __ ] you
did this but then you already know that
he wouldn't like you
yeah so like but if it ever got broader
girls try to hide it and that's where
they go and i don't think that's okay i
i think that you don't have to tell them
but you have to break out with them but
if you know you're especially going
against someone which is like that's
not right but that would be considered
like cohesion because you know you're
willingly doing something like if like
say you're having sex with someone based
on the fact
of like you didn't even if it's never
brought up then that's not something
that's under their control do you know
what i mean like
i can't control like that's like saying
oh i would never date a puppeteer
oh you didn't tell me you were into
puppets that's freaky like
but like if i didn't know ahead of time
like like anything he pulls out
it's different but if you've expressly
told like your partner that this is
something that would make you
uncomfortable
if it had happened then you either
needed to let them know and have a
discussion or
you need to get away from that guy
because it's not something yeah
that's viable for you anymore yeah no
um but there's definitely if you buy
only fans and you won't date a girl with
only fans
you're you're crazy unless you're
willing to go look at a [ __ ] ton of
naked girls on the internet
and pay like hundreds of dollars in
total for this [ __ ]
but you're going to judge her for
putting it there that shit's backhanded
as [ __ ]
thompson i do not
thank you guys for watching this car
conversation with my cousin maddie um
i thought it was really interesting um
do not forget subscribe
to the channel bring that notification
bell and no one send this to my
my family okay and i will talk to you
guys
next time